just imagine living in this 15 million
dollar home your pay to steady salary
supported by a whole team of staff whose
sole purpose is to get you to play at
your best and if you don't perform
you're cut from the team here we go
round three round three and keep it
going no breaks if you think this sounds
like the life of a pro athlete you'd be
right kind of stop your bitching it's
the life of the sports player of the
future live by the lucky few today
this technology replaces old jobs it's
also creating new ones I'm Aki Ito and
I'm here to show you the jobs of the
future my name is Michael small I'm a
professional gamer for someone who's
uneducated in the eSports scene and
doesn't understand how it works the way
I would describe it is it's kind of
similar to a professional athlete it's a
lot of preparation hard work and team
effort thing one guy's above me no trust
me isn't it
ghost gaming pays players like Mike to
compete in video game battles yes that
is a real job now more people watch
video games the Netflix Hulu ESPN and
HBO put together an eSports is already a
billion-dollar industry
[Music]
that's how ghosts can afford to shower
players with all kinds of perks like
this team house it's a 10 bed 16 bath
mansion overlooking Hollywood and it
houses 10 players at a time all in their
late teens and early 20s so when most
people will just take a quick look at
the house we're living in it's a bunch
of teenagers and it's a lot of us so you
would think it's rowdy we're just
reckless but we're professional eSports
players here's the day of a professional
gamer
[Music]
I wake up 9 to 9:30
breakfast chest up chest up let's go 11
a.m. we have workouts that last for an
hour to an hour and a half you go Mike
pushing straight in the ground eight
nine and ten after we do that we hit the
film session and we watch the film on
other teams to see what they do just
taking this time make sure you guys take
your time you don't need to be fancy
with it just need to make sure to hit
the shots you need to hit man after
lunch we played from 1:30 to 7:30 I'm
gonna be lighter and that's just a long
grind of playing against other talented
teams get up we played from lunch to
dinner you have a wild lifestyle with
Todd butter
Hey Dude what looks amazing
Mike's been playing video games since he
was 5 but when his parents got divorced
that's when he really buckled down on
gaming I would just get in my desk turn
my game on it's like I would disappear
and go into another world and forget
about all that when he was 14
Mike qualified in the Pro League of the
popular video game Call of Duty he
became one of the youngest professional
players in the game when I first walked
into the event I was just amazed and
just fell in love with it that's when I
knew this is what I wanted to do that
conversation with his parents telling
them he was pursuing a career as a
professional video gamer
well imagine your kid telling you that
there was a lot of arguments and late
nights
but Mike promise to put school first and
his parents eventually came around well
as a single parent
it wasn't easy in my mind I really
couldn't foresee it as a career
but we were at the mall and some young
boy came up to Mike and he said excuse
me are you Spacely and Mike said yeah
he goes can I have your autograph and I
started to cry and I'm like this is
crazy I'm like he recognized you might
and that was instrumental for me as well
realizing how this is taken off I
started earning money at these
tournaments after my third local event
that was still like one of the best
feelings ever being able to go home and
like look my look that like today I got
paid for playing I wasn't just wasting
my time and I wasn't just making up like
stories and fairy tales just so I could
play video games more Mike didn't want
to discuss his contract but when he
joined ghost it was reported that he and
his teammates shared a fifty thousand
dollar signing bonus and where each
offered a four thousand dollar month's
salary on top of all that my cosa earns
money on the side fans pay to watch and
play on the popular streaming site
twitch Annie OSA sells his own line of
apparel
that all makes for a pretty good living
by the standards of any twenty year old
but it's even better when you consider
that almost all of his expenses from his
rent to his food to his training his
gaming related travel is all paid for
which leaves a lot of room for shopping
can I take them off all right we got the
easies mo Rox
I've been a fan of shoes forever so
there's a lot of times where I spend the
same amount of money on shoes but like
professional sports gaming is not a
lifelong career and there's a ton of
turnover to three months after I met
Mike ghosts dropped him from the team
and he's now back home in New Jersey
this sounds very tragic and nearly end a
player's career but this is a very
common thing in the scene and players
get released and switched around all the
time my advice to young gamers that want
to play professionally you got to stay
patient you got to stay dedicated and
understand that it's gonna take
sacrifice because there's always another
person out there trying to take that
spot but I don't have any plans to give
up the gaming career I'm gonna bounce
back from this and make my mom and dad
proud
you